most people don't get what they want
because you don't follow through enough
you just don't follow through it's based
out of insecurity you start and stop
start and stop you're afraid of hurting
people's feelings you're afraid of what
they're gonna say about you you're
afraid they're gonna judge you we're
afraid of having that L on our personal
resume so we we stop we stop and try to
do something else where we're seeing
more immediate results but if it's your
goal if it's your dream you have to
follow through one of my favorite stores
is Brendan Bouchard and I went to speak
at his event in Phoenix and I knew of
him but I didn't know him at the time it
was his business partner that had me
come out to his event and hired me to
speak there and that's where I met
Brendan for the first time and he asked
me hey what are you working on what can
I help but you know what's next for you
and I said I won't work on my book and
he said I'd love to uh I love the help
I'd love to give you some feedback on
your book I am definitely down for that
hey it's Nina Carmichael and we made
these videos because you're probably the
most ambitious person in your circle but
you know you're capable of off more and
you need a push by surrounding yourself
with the best so today let's learn from
one of the best my husband Evan
Carmichael and learn why the biggest
reason most people don't succeed enjoy
he asked me what my phone number was and
at the time I didn't have a phone I
didn't use a phone number and I said how
about email and he said oh I'm not
really good on email but if that's the
only way then let's do email so we
exchanged emails and uh I didn't I
didn't hear from him so I I followed up
and I said hey Brendan thank you you
know you know great event
um love to talk about
the book like you suggested and didn't
hear back and followed up a couple weeks
later and didn't hear back and followed
up a couple weeks later and then he said
oh man thank you uh I'm super swamped
right now but uh let's either do
come out to my place and we'll do a jam
session or I've got this event coming up
maybe you can come be there I said yeah
I'm down for either which one you want
to do and didn't hear back and then
wrote a couple more messages and didn't
hear back and here's what's really
important
in my head
every time I sent another email I I was
questioning myself I was judging myself
like oh I don't want to bother him
um maybe maybe I'm I'm being too
overwhelming maybe maybe he doesn't
actually want me to come out maybe I'm
offending him maybe you know I'm not
respecting him maybe I'm asking for too
much you know that's that's the thought
in my head before every email where in
reality
he's he's just a busy guy he had a lot
of stuff going on he had a launch that
was happening that I wasn't even aware
of uh that he was planning behind the
scenes and so he is he was you know not
crazy stressed out but he just has a lot
on his plate that he's dealing with and
it's hard to tell ourselves that it's
easier to default to the insecurity of
maybe you're bothering maybe you're
asking too much maybe you're not worthy
maybe you should move on the event that
he talked about me coming to was coming
up
and I still hadn't heard back whether
whether he wanted me there or not or you
know my book launch was coming up too
and I thought
I'm gonna send one more email
just one more email that's it I'm gonna
send one more email and hopefully
something happens if not then I'm done
and um hopefully you know he doesn't
think I'm a loser or whatever
and he he wrote back an email and like
hey sorry man again I'm not super great
on email just been swamped planning all
these things uh yeah come on out come
out to the event speak at the event too
and that was his big event that was you
know 30 to 50 000 a year Mastermind to
be a part of that then I spoke on stage
and then at the event after I spoke
I met with him and Dean graziosi
backstage for an hour over lunch and
planned my entire book strategy that
then led to me getting invited to go to
Brendan's house uh a couple days later
and hang with him and Dean and Tom bilio
and Lewis Howes and Jay Shetty and
Russell Brunson in all sorts of amazing
humans who built giant businesses all of
that happened
because I sent that one more email
because I followed up and I followed up
and I followed up and I followed up and
it wasn't that he hated me or that he
thought I sucked or that I was being
overwhelming or whatever that that I
kept following up just had the
persistence there's a lot of
opportunities there in front of you
right now
that
just are not happening because there's
not enough follow-up there's not enough
persistence and and I
the reasons why you're not doing it are
based in reality right I mean I could be
overwhelming it's it's possible it's
possible that he thinks that I'm
overwhelming that I'm not given enough
value that I'm being too selfish that
I'm bothering him I mean it's possible
but we default to just assuming that
instead of actually finding out
and we miss out on a lot of upside and
so here's what I found that really helps
one
you schedule it in
schedule it in every X number of weeks
right so every two weeks I would send in
another email every two weeks every two
weeks every two weeks every two weeks
every two weeks every two weeks and I
never felt like doing it because every
time I saw that in my task list
I I didn't want to do it like ah you
know let's give it another let's give it
another few days let's give it another
week you know I never wanted to do it
but because it was in my calendar I did
it you will never want to do it because
you're afraid right underneath it is
really just fear it's insecurity you'll
never want to do it so you schedule it
in every two weeks or every week or
every month or whatever the thing is
that makes sense to the timeline that
you're on
you schedule it in so that you have to
do it
so when it came up I knew I had even
though I didn't want to even though my
heart was beaten
I still went off and I did it second
thing is
lead with the intention before you write
the email before you make the call
before you do the follow-up like what's
the intention is your intention to screw
this person over is your intention to
just suck up their time is your
intention to negotiate a bad deal for
them hopefully not
if you're if you're a subscriber of this
channel uh hopefully it's with its
positivity and hope and belief and and
mutual you know uh benefits and so if
you lead with that intention every time
it's really unlikely that they're going
to
come back in a really negative way
the truth of the matter is they're
probably just really busy maybe they're
doing something
insane in their life maybe they have a
health scare maybe they're in the
hospital maybe their mom's in the
hospital right like you never know
what's going on behind the scenes
and if you leave with intention as
opposed to a copy paste email or just
some kind of spam if you if you leave
with I love this person I want to do
something with them I want to help I I
want to I want to learn like if that's a
positive intention going in your your
call your email your follow-up will just
be a lot better it'll be a lot better
and people will feel it I forget who it
was I want to say it was
ah no I forget who it is I'm thinking
princess dive I don't think it was her I
wanna I don't forget who it was where
she would say before I send an email
thank you
I would always smile
I would think about the person
and I would smile before I I wrote an
email or wrote a letter
and it would always change
the the vibe of the letter right like if
you're thinking love kindness smiling
before you make a video before you do a
DM before you do a uh an email right
like if you're thinking that
chances are you'll make them smile
you know like if you're smiling
before you do it you're probably gonna
make them smile
and so just taking that little pause to
reflect on what is my intention here
instead of defaulting to insecurity and
the stress on your side
default into let's lead with positivity
let's smile let's leave with love
you'd be amazed at how many great things
happen
so those two things
one you put in your calendar
until you get a response like if
somebody if somebody says no
okay at least you got a response
but again it's likely going to be a
loving no because you followed up so
many times and you've always LED with a
positive intention and love and kindness
they might just say I'm just you know
what I can't do this right now or I'm
not interested or or hey sorry I haven't
gotten back to you let's do this
right A lot of times it's just a timing
a lot of times your timing is way off
and it's not your timing it just doesn't
fit into their life or their world right
now but in two weeks it might or in two
months it might or in two years it might
and if you're following up every two
weeks every two weeks every two weeks
every two weeks and you're leading with
love and kindness and with a positive
intent amazing things will happen
you have a great Mission inside you
you have a desire to serve and the help
and to create great things for the
people who you work with
right like that that is at the core of
Who You Are
and that needs to be spread
and at the beginning when people don't
know who you are it's a little harder to
get attention and get on people's radar
but if you are consistently following
through consistently even in the face of
not getting any response you just
consistently because it's on your
calendar you're consistently following
through and you're leading with the
intention of Love kindness positivity
great things will happen
I promise you great things will happen
rule number two feel the fear and do it
anyway
that means you are playing small and not
doing anything that is worth doing you
should be dreaming big you should be
pushing boundaries and in that push
comes fear instead of trying to be
Fearless adopt a mindset that you want
to feel the fear and do it anyway
otherwise you will never take on big
projects and you'll never accomplish
your mission and you'll always live
below the potential that you know you're
capable of so just came back from
speaking in Phoenix with with Dean
graziosi Brendan burchard Eric Thomas
1500 people amazing session my greatest
fear is disappointing people my greatest
fear is I'm going to get on stage and
bomb and disappoint the people who are
paying money to be there as an expensive
ticket to get in and also I'm going to
disappoint Dean graziosi and Brandon
burchard and people who brought me here
to speak right it's their event
and I have to be the last speaker on the
last day to come in and give them a good
performance right I don't want to let
them down we've never worked together
before these are the thoughts that are
going through my head and so I'm
backstage
and actually the first day I get there
I'm I've got the next day right I've got
my whole day ahead of me and I'm gonna
speak the next day and then I get a call
so I'm in my hotel room and I'm
practicing I get a call and said hey
Evan can you come down right now
we might want to have you speak right
now let's figure it out and in my head
it's like right now
I thought I was going on tomorrow I was
in the middle of practice saying I
haven't even gone through the second
half of my my speech but the default
reaction is yep I'm on my way
and I run downstairs to get to the event
they end up saying it's okay we want you
back on tomorrow usual time perfect no
problem
so now I got the whole night to prepare
again I wake up the next morning I'm
preparing in the morning and then I'm
getting down down to the stage and
initial supposed to go on at 9am and
then that then it got switched to 10 am
then that got switched to 11 A.M and
then they want to take off 10 minutes of
my time because run a little bit behind
so in 15 minutes instead of 60 minutes
and then changing my deck changing the
slide that I have and then I'm sitting
backstage and I'm waiting to come on and
it feels like the MC's he's building me
up and he's taking lots of time to
introduce me like just bring me on right
and every time I'm sitting there
worried
stressed out
afraid
saying that it's hard this is difficult
I'm afraid
my heart's beaten out of my chest
because I'm still thinking I don't want
to go up there and disappoint people
but instead of being Fearless it's like
no I'm afraid and this is the best
because everything I want is on the
other side of the sphere
then I'm gonna go off and I'm gonna do
the best that I have and every new thing
that comes at me they kept saying man
you're so easy to work with you're so
easy going yep meanwhile like I'm
panicking and freaking out inside and
it's not it's not about putting on a
show it's not about showing people that
I'm I'm afraid
it's about me telling myself that I do
difficult things
some people say when you are nervous
tell yourself that you're excited
because it's the same feeling inside you
that when you're about to go on stage or
have a big call or do something that
you're afraid to do you're nervous tell
yourself you're excited I don't want
that
I tell myself I'm nervous
and I do things that make me nervous I
love that I do things that make me
nervous I build my self-esteem and
self-respect and self-pride from jumping
in on the things that make me nervous
you want to do things that make you
nervous
and so I got on stage and and did a
pretty good job we had a little
miscommunication on the ending and uh
flubbed it a little bit but
I get backstage and Brandon Richards
running back like oh my God you crushed
it so much energy I love that guy and
now I'm on to the next thing
and if there's nothing in my calendar
ahead that is scary difficult hard that
makes me feel afraid
then I'm not growing
and you're not going to so I've got a
three-step process that I'm going to
walk you through that can help you step
into your fears that I think will help
step number one is understand what is
your big mission what are you trying to
accomplish what is the big mission that
you're on I want to solve the world's
biggest problem I want to spread more
belief I think the world's biggest
problem is there aren't enough people
who believe in themselves and their
Michael Jordan level Talent that's what
I'm helping every single dude every
single do every single day for the rest
of my life that is my mission
what is your big mission what is the
thing that you're afraid of doing what
is that giant thing right now me
stepping on stage at Brendan and Dean's
event makes sense because I'm trying to
spread my mission what is your big
mission number two is what's the next
step that you're afraid to take
if you want to go off and have a big
impact change a lot of lives you're
going to have to do things you've never
done before because the way you're doing
it now the growth that you're on now is
not fast enough you're not going to hit
your target it's not going to happen
it's going to require a bolder more
confident more courageous version of you
and how do you get that by stepping into
the light
by stepping into your nerves by stepping
into your fears that's how you grow
that's how you emerge stronger so what's
the next step for you your big mission
just came up with it step number one
what's your big mission great what is
the next step that you must take to move
that mission forward that you are afraid
of and then step number three is commit
to doing it right now
commit to doing it right now you are not
allowed anymore to think of something
that's big that's exciting that it that
is
game changing for you that gets you
pumped up and ready to go you're not
allowed to think of that and then be
afraid and then not do something you
need to stop teaching yourself that that
you come up with ideas then you get
afraid and then you don't have momentum
and you play small you need to break
that cycle so we've just gone through it
you came up with your big mission
you can with what the next step is now
you need to commit to doing it commit to
someone else that you're gonna do it
make your video talking about it send
that email you need to send out text the
person that you need to text post it to
your Facebook or Instagram tell people
that you're gonna do this thing commit
while you're feeling it right now and
then you feel your heart beating boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
you're scared you're gonna wake up
tomorrow's like holy cow what did I just
create they're going
you're committed to doing the thing that
you're a badass at because you're
chasing down a dream because you have a
big Vision because you don't want to
play small for the rest of your life
because you're ready for this
that's why you committed now let's go
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number three follow through
on your goals we give up too easily on
our goals because we've proven to
ourselves that we can't follow through
on our goals every time you set a goal
and you don't follow through you're
creating the pattern in your head the
mindset the identity that I'm the kind
of person who doesn't follow through
so what happens the next time you set a
goal well your your brain will kick in
to say you're not going to do that how
many times have you set a goal for
yourself it might be some big giant goal
right like I'm gonna crush this year and
I'm gonna be here by the end of the year
awesome might be some big goal but
chances are even the little ones even
the little goals like I'm gonna work out
today or I'm gonna eat well today or I'm
gonna make that call today how many
times have you set even a little goal
for yourself and then not follow through
you didn't do it
you're not allowed to do that anymore
you have to be very intentional about
the goals you set for yourself and then
once you set them you have to follow
through because what's happening is you
don't believe you anymore
the next time you come up with another
goal you say I'm going to create this
thing
I'm gonna get this thing done you might
believe it in the half second that you
decided you're gonna do it
I know what happens your brain's gonna
take over and say you're not gonna do
that thing are you crazy
what makes you think you're gonna do
that you didn't do these other 100
things you said you were gonna do either
your goals don't count until they're
hard
and it starts
with as soon as you set a goal you
follow through and expect it to be
difficult if it's easy it's a gift
expect it to be difficult and show
yourself that you do difficult things so
for example I'm I'm filming today switch
my hands and it's getting tired from
holding the phone all day I'm filming
today I'm not I'm not at my place
not my usual setting I'm not in my usual
gear uh you know I like having my camera
set up and my light and my microphone
and all of it
I can't do it today but today is my
filming day I don't tomorrow I can't
film because I got other stuff I'm
working my YouTube course I'm working my
membership program working on promote my
new book build to serve go check that
out build the serve
so it has to get done today
what many people would do is say well
whatever I'll do it next week you put it
off you put it off I'll do it tomorrow
and then tomorrow something else happens
and you don't get it done
I adopt the mindset that it doesn't
count until it's hard that if I'm
sitting down to record videos with
everything perfectly set up that's a
bonus but I expect things to get hard I
expect life to throw a wrench in my face
right I expect difficult situations that
come up my goals don't count until
they're hard
and I am the kind of person who follows
through on the things I say I'm going to
do that's my belief with myself
let alone what I'll tell other people
to myself it's not acceptable that it's
video day and I'm not making videos
and so I'm filming outside and I'm
layered up and I went through this
exercise this morning part of what I do
every morning is I think about what's my
goal for the day and what would prevent
me from accomplishing my goal right I
say I want to do this what's going to be
my roadblock and I'll pre-plan this in
advance what's going to be a roadblock
for me to not filming so in my head I
said well I have to film today I'm not
going to be at home so I'm going to film
today I'm going to film outside what's
going to prevent me from actually doing
it it's like well if it's too cold
right so what's my solution and I'll
write it down I'll prepare for it I'm
going to bundle up so I've got I've got
my hat on I've got my winter jacket on
I've got I've got two layers you can't
see it I got this hoodie with with the
thumb holes and then I got this hoodie
which is the orange one the the gold one
right then I've got a t-shirt on
underneath that too just stay warm
right so I'm I'm making it so that I can
follow through and accomplish my goals
but I've tied my self-identity to doing
difficult things to following through
when it's hard and so
I want you to commit the less goals once
you think about just one goal that you
have for yourself what's one goal
success equals habits so what's a habit
that you have that you want to keep
that's important to you and don't tell
yourself you're going to do it
unless you're actually going to follow
through and do it make fewer goals and
then stick to them
that allows you to build the discipline
and the willpower
because when you believe that you can
follow through guess what happens you're
way more likely to follow through
when you believe that you can't because
you've told yourself this ongoing story
and proven to yourself that you can't
that you don't follow through then
that's what's going to continue to
perpetuate and then you're never going
to go off and accomplish your goals but
you know that you're capable of more and
you live secretly knowing that you
resent it you regret it you're
disappointed in yourself
how do you get self-love how do you get
rid of the disappointment how do you
build self-esteem self-confidence
willpower all of it comes from doing
difficult things and committing to
yourself and following through
so pick fewer goals step one pick fewer
goals
step two expect them to be difficult
life is going to throw a wrench at you
step three plan four difficulties in
that what could throw you off course
today from not following through look I
almost slipped I almost slipped in some
ice what would happen if I slipped on
that ice
I would keep filming I would film from
the floor
when I broke my neck I filmed with my
broken neck the collar the massive pain
there's tons of videos on it
if I slipped on that ice right now
it would not be acceptable for me
to to stop filming
right and I would tell my editor
Christina leave all that in leave the
following leave the ow leave the like
camera pointing at the sky where you can
only hear me groaning and then see me
pick up the phone and start finishing
this video and then I would celebrate
myself
right once you do it and it's hard you
have to celebrate yourself you pat
yourself on the box I'm amazing I just
did that is it the best video of all
time no could I have done way better a
hundred percent
but I did that
and that starts building the belief
system that you can do the next thing
and the next thing and the next thing
and the next thing
so pick that goal
expect it to be hard
plan for it to be difficult and what
your solution is going to be
and then go off and do it
celebrate
because you're awesome
and I want to see you win rule number
four play to win most people are so
afraid to lose that they don't even try
so when you have nothing when you're at
the bottom you've got nothing to lose
and so it's very easy to go off and try
but as soon as there are Stakes as soon
as you've won just a little bit now you
risk losing something and this is where
most people back down and play small for
life and so you need to decide are you
playing life to win or are you playing
life afraid to lose so I look at my
YouTube channel as an example when I
started it there was no risk nobody knew
me nobody's watching my videos I could
go and fail didn't make a difference I
could try a whole bunch of different
things whenever the algorithm changed I
got pumped because the people who are
ahead of me were complaining and would
would be romantic and would want it to
go back the way it was and I'm like hey
algorithm change amazing let's go I'm
gonna learn that new thing
but now I've gotten bigger
right now I think I have more views than
anybody in The Entrepreneur Space on
YouTube and it's easy to now be
protective it's easy to say well I built
this thing I don't want to lose and I
hate that I need to I need to destroy
that I want to be constantly losing
constantly testing constantly risking
now not risking at all not not putting
everything on the line just for one
thing but to be willing to test willing
to fail as an example
I split up my channels
I split up my channels into eight
different channels I got an advice from
Matt Gillen he's one of five people who
who are put on my hand as people who I
listened to for YouTube advice right
here's one of the five and another one
in the five said don't do it so I got
five people who I listened to about
YouTube one person says split up your
channel one person says don't do it what
do I do I have to do it just to see
because I know what not split into my
channel looks like it's what I'm
currently doing
but splitting on my channel I won't know
if it's going to work or not until I
actually go off and do it and so I did
and here's a news flash it's not working
yet right my other channels the most I
think has 8 000 subscribers they have
two around 8 000 subscribers and the
others are smaller and they're growing
every day and they're getting a momentum
every day but overall my subscriber
growth is down My Views are down my
revenue is down everything is down it's
all down watch time is down everything
is down is it a big failure I don't know
maybe I'm gonna give it more time and
see
I'm gonna give it more time and see it's
a risk right I went from making three
videos a day on one channel to making
one video a day across a couple channels
and then you know once a week on some
channels and we have eight different
channels now it's more headache it's
more management maybe ultimately it will
work out or maybe in six months I'll
come back and say man that was a giant
failure that sucked
but I won't know until they try and
that's that's where you need to risk it
that's where you need to try you need to
see you need to test you need to taste
it because if I just take that mindset
every time of saying well this is what's
always worked and so I need to protect
this and stay true to this and that's it
I can never change one I'm gonna
eventually hate my life I'm gonna hate
my business because you need to evolve
you need to change you need to grow what
what got you success is amazing but if
you if you then do that same thing over
and over and over forever you're gonna
feel like you got yourself a job why did
you leave your job to do this thing to
have creativity and freedom and fun not
to do the same thing over and over and
over and over and over again right you
have to evolve your business as you
evolve as a human or or your business
will start to flounder and suffer and it
happens to so many entrepreneurs you see
this growth and then you see this
Plateau this long plateau and people
start to get more and more bored with
their business and with their life
because they're not evolving their
business as they evolved as humans right
so if I did that with my YouTube channel
I would I would start to struggle and
suffer and you see it with a lot of
YouTubers now maybe in in six months I
end up going back right or maybe I never
go back but there's always going to be
some new iterations some new versions
some new thing that that I'm willing to
risk even though I've grown my channel
I'm I'm among the biggest in the space
and so always having that mindset I want
to win
I want to win I want to keep pushing I I
want to just not play life trying not to
lose
and so when again at the beginning it's
easy
but once you start building something up
and that's in your business that's in
your relationships like your
relationship will need to evolve too
what got you there is a good starting
point but you're gonna evolve and and
your spouse or your boyfriend girlfriend
they're gonna evolve too and can you
evolve together I think the test of a
relationship is how much can you evolve
together
because if you're growing and learning
and improving yourself and and your
partner is just staying still you're
eventually going to grow apart or if
your partner's going a different way
you're going to grow a party even faster
but you're gonna grow nobody just wants
to stay static forever and so can you
weave and grow together that's the game
so you have to decide are you playing to
win or you're playing just not to lose
so how do you play to win I'm going to
give you a three-step process that I
think can help set number one is use the
fear of regret use regret regret is very
powerful because if you look at people
who are at the end of their life
in old age homes who can't do it anymore
who can't chase their goals anymore if
they're filled with regret like I I knew
I had potential I knew I could have done
something but I didn't because I was
just too afraid
use that power for yourself you're
afraid to do something you're afraid to
change you're afraid to to risk
something you're gonna be 95 you're
gonna be on your deathbed soon like
imagine you're there right now
and you never took the thing that you
wanted to do you never got an answer you
never chased it down because you were
afraid
you're gonna you're gonna hate your life
that's where most people lie but the
good news is you can come back
to to this year right you can step back
into your body right now and say I can
do it
and so adopting the mindset that you
would rather know and fail than not know
not knowing equals regret forever
knowing and failing you can deal with it
you very rarely regret the things that
you do
it's most often the things that you did
not do that you were afraid to do the
actions not taken that people regret and
so don't be like that whenever you're
afraid of doing something take that test
use the regret test imagine yourself at
95 in a rocking chair in an old age home
and you never did the thing that you're
thinking about right now would you
regret that and whatever you think that
you regret not doing you have to summon
the courage to do it right now step
number two is understand that your
setback primes your comeback your
setbacks prime your comebacks nobody's
on top always right it says drop and
then you come back even higher
and so whatever you want to go off and
do right whatever change you want to go
off and make
chances are one is not fatal like you
can always come back to something
right if you want to take a year off
after University to go be an
entrepreneur instead of going to that
job where if you're if you're in a job
that you hate you say you know what I
can always get another job so I'm going
to try for a year doing my own business
it's not fatal you can always come back
and do it you can always come back and
get that crappy job you know you're
capable of it you know you're probably
more than capable of it of what you're
doing right now but the thing is you're
probably not going to go back to it
right like you're leaving it for a
reason you don't go back to your
ex-girlfriend or ex-boyfriend you go
back to that crappy boss because in that
time even though you may have failed a
whole bunch of times you've learned and
you've grown you're a stronger person
because of it it's that setback primes
you for your comeback because now you're
a stronger person you're capable of more
and you'll find the next PATH the path
that you chose may not be the ultimate
path for you but you know that the path
you left is not the path for you either
and so better than sticking on some path
that you know that you don't love
it's better to go off and explore the
test The Taste is to try most people
don't do that enough and they're so
worried about the failure you're worried
about this New Path failing and not
working out
you can tell yourself you can always go
back to that thing and you can and the
facts are you can't you can go back and
do what you're doing before
which probably won't even if the thing
that you jump to doesn't work out
you're not going back to where you were
because you're strong you've grown and
that'll set you up for the comeback
that'll set you up for the next great
thing in your life because you won't
find the great thing doing the thing
that you hate doing and step number
three is say it's the best
I've trained myself that whenever
something really negative is happening
to me I say this is the best
this is the best
what was the best part of me going on my
tour for 90 days 23 cities breaking my
neck broke my neck in two spots had a
concussion three stables in my head I
still have you can kind of see down
there
how do I point right there right there
got got my my two neck braces that I had
to sleep in and be in basically all day
long except for a 10 minute shower that
was the best part of the tour
not just positive attitude like it's the
best
actually the best because that negative
situation that that you're dealing with
right now makes you stronger it shows
you what you're capable of thank you
your purpose comes from your pain
ultimately right like the thing that you
want to do for the rest of your life
comes from the most painful moment in
your life whatever you struggle the most
with is the thing that you want to help
other people through
and so thank you for that crazy pain
somebody hasn't been through pain never
accomplishes anything amazing
so thank you this pain that I'm that I'm
going through right now amazing let's go
this is the best
if you could just change that mindset
tweak the next time you find yourself
complaining angry upset frustrated tell
yourself just try it this is the best
this is the best this is my chance to
show myself in the world what I'm made
of this is my chance to grow this is the
best
and watch how quickly it puts you into a
resourceful State instead of being
hopeless and complaining and upset and
frustrated now you feel like things are
possible
now you feel hopeful now you're
resourceful and now you're way more
likely to solve the problem instead of
sitting there complaining about it
best rule number five the last one
before our very special bonus clip be
bold what would the boldest version of
you do think about your mission think
about your goals think about what you
are trying to accomplish you've got what
you're doing now but think about what
the boldest version of you if you summon
the boldest version of you into
existence right now what would he or she
tell you to do so when I did my tour
earlier this year was 90 days 23 cities
and at first I want to do it for free I
love doing free coffee shop meetups
every time I travel to a new city and I
told my agent Steve from New York hey
man this is my idea he said you need to
charge for the event you got to play
bigger you gotta you gotta do a bolder
version of you and it it's freaked me
out it scared me because I don't want to
disappoint people in the idea of
charging for something and then me
disappointing people and then hitting
that fear every four days because I got
up in a new city every three to four
days for 90 days was me being able to
conquer my fears and so Steve pushed me
and I have Steve's voice in my head it's
like you need to play bigger you got to
do something Bolder what's the next step
and so I'm looking at my next tour
coming up in 2020 around my book built
the serve and I'm trying to think how do
I make it even bigger how do I make it
even Bolder because what I've done has
been great and it's not trying to take
away from what I've done it's amazing
I'm proud of myself I'm grateful awesome
and I know I'm capable of more and I
know I need to do something at the next
level because if I want to go off and
accomplish my mission I need to because
at the rate I'm going right now I'm not
going to hit a billion people I'm not
going to solve the world's biggest
problem
I'm not gonna have the impact and reach
that I know I can have unless I demand
more boldness bigger scale from myself
on a daily basis and so for me having
Steve's voice in my head having Elon
Musk voice in my head having Steve Jobs
and epigenini and my parents and Kanye
West and Howard Schultz constantly in my
head the content that I make is for
myself
it's selfish for myself and then I share
with you guys and thankfully you like it
so I could build a business around it
and hire your team and keep creating
more
what makes you bold what makes you come
alive and how do you summon that
creature on a daily basis when you if
you wake up and you daily every day
consistently are bringing the boldest
version of you even for one year if you
woke up every day for one year and
summoned the boldest version of you your
life is gonna look dramatically
different one year from today so how do
you start playing a bigger game and
being more bold I'm gonna give you a
three-step process that I think is going
to help step number one what would the
boldest version of you do just ask in
that question just taking five minutes
sit down grab your coffee eat your
breakfast have no distractions and just
think about it for five minutes what
would the boldest version of you to what
would the boldest version of you today
do
what would you do look at your day ahead
look at look at your plans look at what
you've got up in your schedule today if
you were bold if you summoned the
boldest version of you today what would
you do differently
and in summon the strength and summon
the courage and go do that thing set
number two is think big and act small
think big act small you have to think
big because you're an entrepreneur
You've Got Big Dreams big Ambitions we
want to change the world you got an
important Mission a vision that's
driving you every day right I feel it
I'm connected to it too I got a big
Vision that I never want to end I want
to chase it down for the rest of my life
but sometimes the big Vision yes it is
empowering and yes it is inspiring but
sometimes it seems too big sometimes it
seems impossible sometimes it seems like
we're never going to do it without
getting venture capital and Partnerships
and and a huge team and all of these
things and you stack it on top of each
other and then you don't do anything
because it's too big an idea that you
can't do it alone
that's where you need to act small think
big big Vision but act small like what's
the smallest simplest easiest thing that
you can just do right now
it might be just picking up your phone
and making a video you want to have a
YouTube channel you want to build
momentum create create a video today
right now and you won't know what you're
talking about and you won't have perfect
audio and you won't have the great
lighting it will be garbage editing
great because the biggest thing that's
missing the biggest thing that's missing
from you from your mission actually
happening is momentum you're a genius
you've got great ideas that thing that's
in here needs to be birthed but there's
no momentum you're not doing enough on a
daily basis to actually create that
thing and get it out to the world so
think big act small and step number
three is to understand that your bucket
list is your excuse list people walk
around with a bucket list of things that
they want to do before they die the
problem is you've given yourself until
you die as your timeline
it's an excuse let's look at what's on
that bucket list everything on there is
excuses
you've come up with stories as to why
you can't do it I just came back from
speaking at Dean graziosis and Brendan
burchard's event in Phoenix and there
was a woman who was in front of me said
hey I've got dancing in my bucket list
he found out that I had owned Toronto
Dan salsa and now dances on my bucket
list like don't say that your bucket
list is your excuse list
and then she was taken aback but then
she looked down and she you know pulled
up her dress a little bit and and you
could see her she had a broken foot or
something wrong with one of her legs
I said great
she's showing it to me as if oh and now
I'm supposed to understand your
situation that's why you can't go
dancing she showed it to me and then I
said okay can you march can you do this
can you just can you do this can you
march says yeah I can March I can walk
great give me your hands
and I picked her up and we started doing
merengue and I was doing all these turn
patterns and making her move and turning
around and she had her first Moringa
dance and then she realized all I need
is somebody to hold on to I can dance I
just need somebody to hold on to
don't wait until five years later Ten
Years Later until you die for that
bucket list to happen today your bucket
list is your excuse list stop telling
yourself all the reasons why you can't
do something and if it was important
enough to you you'll Chase it down
I'm passionate about this I'm going to
tell you one more story there was one
guy same event who says getting to the
top of whatever mountain is his
on his bucket list
but he doesn't have the money to do it
and he doesn't have the time to do it
and all this stuff and he's doing all
these little things instead of chasing
down his one big goal
if he hit the top of the mountain
everything else in his life would change
would be different he'll come back a
different person a different human all
the things that he thinks are so
important to him right now
will not be important when he comes back
these little projects that are
distracting him from doing the big thing
that he wants to do will disappear he'll
come back a new human with a whole
different path ahead of him
you have to figure out a way to get to
the top of that mountain you have to
figure out look at your bucket list and
recognize that's just a list of excuses
you've got there pick the thing that you
actually care about and go chase it down
immediately
some people are built to serve the world
some people want to have a giant Mission
a giant Vision you want to impact the
lives of millions of people that's me
that may be you if you're watching this
that's most entrepreneurs I think you
have a giant vision and you want to
change the world but some people are
built to serve the 25 closest people to
them if I look at my wife Nina as an
example she doesn't have a giant Mission
she doesn't have a giant Vision but she
still wants to serve if you're not happy
if you're not happy in life it's because
you're not serving you're not serving
deeply enough to
care most about or you're not serving
broadly enough to have a big enough
impact on the people around you your
community your country your continent
the world right
so entrepreneurs will default too I
think we want to serve the world they
did functional MRIs on the brain
functional MRIs and they studied the
impact
of serving of helping other people and
it showed that when you serve other
people when you get the satisfaction you
help somebody else out it touches the
same part of your brain as eating food
and having sex which are both also
pretty important things in life I think
you would agree
and so you're built to serve and and
they went deeper into the study and they
found that giving triggers it more than
receiving
so all of the stories that we know of
how giving is great and Santa Claus and
you know it's better to give them to
receive and all this stuff right the
things that we've been told in our
stories that have been handed down to us
is backed up by science it's backed up
by science so if you're not happy right
now
if you're a little bit low right now the
easiest path out is service serve go
help people if you woke up every day and
felt like the work that you did matter
to somebody either to again the closest
people to you like my wife who's still
in touch with their friends from
kindergarten in China
to someone like me who wants to have a
giant impact and reach a billion people
around the world if you're not happy all
you have to do is start to serve
so then it becomes a question of well
how do you serve how do you either build
your vision or find a vision well it
comes from whatever you struggled with
right the thing that you struggled with
the most your purpose comes from your
pain and this is what I outlined in my
book built to serve check it out build
the serve there's a link in the
description go check it out support me
because it's a super important book that
I think is going to really help a lot of
people including you your purpose comes
from your pain whatever you struggle the
most with is the thing you want to help
other people with for life so serving
the world or serving the closest people
to you can take on many forms
and you'll love helping people just
because that's how we're wired as people
but who specifically do you want to help
and how makes a difference
holding the door for somebody down here
right like if somebody's gonna somebody
was crossing the Rocks this is Rocky
part over here on the beach way down
there in the corners really rocky area
and if I help somebody cross right it
was an older couple that couldn't get
across so we went first and helped them
cross helping that makes me feel good
right because it's serving others but
it's not as deep
that level of service is surface level
it's still fantastic it's great it makes
you feel good you can check off good
deep for the day but it's not as good as
helping an entrepreneur
because I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur it's the most painful
moment in my life is quitting on my
business and I know what it's like and I
want to make the path a little bit
easier for other people so helping
random stranger is still good better
than not but helping an entrepreneur
fills me up to a level that that is on
the level of my soul
and so you need to find the same thing
for you whatever you felt the most
worthless as a human being you struggle
the most as a person you felt worthless
you felt disposable as a person
that feeling that emotional feeling you
want to help other people not feel the
same way
I know no no no no no that there are so
many people there are so many people who
currently are what you used to be there
are so many people who currently feel
the same way that you used to feel and
your purpose is to help those people
forever that will never get old I'll
love helping entrepreneurs when I'm 95.
I struggle the lowest point in my life
as an entrepreneur as a human was when I
was 19. and I quit on my business
partner and I felt worthless and now I'm
I'm 39 I'm almost 40 in May I turn 40.
and it doesn't get old two decades later
I'm Still Loving It helping
entrepreneurs how you do it changes it's
YouTube now it'll be Holograms in 10
years it'll be VR right you'll watch me
through your goggles or I'll be beaming
into your living room it's gonna change
with time but the purpose the mission
the vision doesn't change I want to
solve the world's biggest problem
people don't believe in themselves
enough
and so it starts with the foundation
point that you were built to serve you
were built to serve you want to have an
impact you want to make a difference you
want to wake up every day and feel like
the work that you do matters
and serving people lights up your brain
like food and sex you have to do it
how do you serve through your pain the
point is to live in the pain the point
is to use that pain as a conduit to help
other people escape the pain not to go
back and relive it over and over and
over again but to recognize that that
pain however you suffered whoever might
have caused something to you was the
greatest gift that they could have given
you
because now you're going to go off and
make sure that millions of people around
the world don't feel the same way that
you felt
you're built to serve now go out and get
it
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome and if you
want to watch Evan's top 10 rules for
Success check out the video next to me I
think you can enjoy continue to believe
I will see you there I encourage
entrepreneurs to go through a three-step
process which is eliminate automate
delegate so you look at the work that
you're doing and maybe you shouldn't be
doing it at all like before you give it
to somebody else maybe